okay I want to begin by giving some
comments regarding their Wikipedia
assignment so I sent out an email about
this last night and so first of all you
know thank you for your contributions to
to this assignment to Wikipedia it plays
a really important role in educating a
wider audience
what this subject is about because as
many of you have experienced the first
time if you heard of some term you have
no idea what it is you put it into
Google and often Wikipedia entry is one
of the top results that come up and what
gets written there actually plays a
fairly influential role in educating a
broader audience about what this topic
is about and so I won't you emphasize
that you know this is not simply some
homework assignment it's something that
it's a real contribution and it's
something that contributes to the
dissemination of knowledge and for that
it is really important to do a good job
to do a write to do a well so that next
time someone maybe even yourselves you
know have you forgotten what the subject
is about and go back and you want to
look it up again and remind yourself you
will have a useful resource to look into
but also let's say someone wants to find
out you know what is extrema graph
theory about what is additive
combinatorics about you want them to
land on a page that points you to the
right type of places right that points
you to use for resources that opens
doors so that you can explore further
and and some of the contributions indeed
server well in that purpose it opens
doors to many things and part of the
spirit of this assignment is for you to
do your own research do your own
literature search to learn more about
the subject you know more than what has
been taught in this in these lectures so
that you can write about it on Wikipedia
you can link to more references you know
show the world what this subject is
about okay can you do with our program
so we spent the past few lectures
developing tools regarding the structure
of set Edition so that we can
proof Fryman theorem so that's been our
goal for the past few lectures and today
will finally prove Freeman's theorem but
let me first remind you the statement so
in fragments theorem we would like to
show that if you are in a substance if
you're in the integers you have a set a
path bang the doubling doubling constant
constant K then the set must be
contained in a small generalized
arithmetic progression down the
dimension and size only a constant
factor larger than a we developed
various tools the past three lectures
building up to various intermediate
results but we also collected this very
nice set of tools for proving Freeman's
theorem so let me review some of them
which we'll encounter again today learn
the karuta inequality tells you that if
you have a set where small toppling then
the further inter weighted sums are also
controlled so I want you to think of
these parameters as you know K is a
constant so okay some powers to a
constant but also I don't really care
about polynomial changes in case so I
changes in K and view this constant more
or less as the origin okay itself so if
some if the a plus a is around the same
side st. and further iterations also do
not change the sizes very much rules are
covering lemma right so this was some
statement that if X plus B looks like it
could be covered by copies of B just in
terms of their sizes alone then
in fact X could be covered by a small
number translates of a slightly larger
ball but here can be any set we have
this thing called remodeling lemma in
particular consequence of it is that if
a has small doubling then there exists a
prime and that's not too much bigger
than the size of a and a very large
proportion an eighth of a subset of
eighth such that the subset a prime is
prime 1/8 isomorphic to a subset of Z
mod n so even though you start with a
set as potentially very spread out
provided I have small doubling I can
pick out a pretty large piece of it and
model it by something in a fairly
small cyclic group and here the modeling
is eight isomorphic so it preserves sums
up to eight term songs we had boggling
buffs lemma so now we're inside a small
cyclic group of a large subset of a
small cyclic group then pokéballs lemma
says that - a - - a contains a
large-bore set a large structure within
this iterated some set and last time we
showed that via geometry of numbers via
minkovski second theorem one can deduce
that every bore set of small dimension
and and small with contains of large
with contains a proper gaap that's
pretty large so putting these two
together putting the last two things
together we obtain that if you have a
subset of the cyclic group and and prime
okay so here previous statements so n is
prime then and a is pretty large then -
a - - a contains a proper generalized
arithmetic progression of dimension at
most alpha to the minus 2 and size at
least 1 over 42 d times ok so just
starting from the size of a - a - - a
contains a pretty large gaap so we're
gonna put all of these ingredients
together and show that you can now
contain the original set a in a small JP
alright so just from knowing that some
subset of it - a - 2 m so two things - a
prime minus 2 a prime contains this
large JP we're going to use it to boost
it up to a cover
okay so now let's proof friends they're
using the modeling memo using the modern
dilemma the corollary of the modeling
memo we find that since a plus a this
size at most K times the size of a there
exists sound Prime and at most 2k to the
16 I'm saying and so I'm just copying
the consequence of this modeling memo so
I find a pretty large subset of a such
that a prime is Fryman 8 isomorphic to a
subset of Zima in now applying the final
corollary with alpha being the size of
this a prime which is at least the size
of a over N which is at least 1 over 16
to the times K to the power 16 so olbes
constants we see that to a prime - okay
so let me actually let me change the
letters and call a prime B Prime
subset of a is coffee okay so to be - to
be now contains a large GA p and the g
AP has dimension D bounded right so the
dimension is bounded by alpha to the
minus two so so it's some constant and
the size is pretty large size is at
least one over 40 if you only care about
constants just remember that everything
that depends on K or D is a constant
okay because b is Fryman eight
isomorphic eight isomorphic to be is a
prime is a subset of a and b is the
subset of Z mod b is a subset of Z mod n
that a Prime's a isomorphic to so since
P is eight isomorphic to a prime every
GA p in B also so if you think about
what eight isomorphism preserves you
find that if you look at to be - to be
it must be too friendly to isomorphic to
to a prime minus Q eight right so the
point of Fryman isomorphism is that we
just want in to preserve enough additive
structure while we're doing to preserve
all the additive structure
but just enough additive structure to do
what we need to do and being able to
preserve an arithmetic progression or in
general or generalized arithmetic
progression requires you to preserve
Fryman to isomorphism and that's where
the ink comes in I want to analyze to be
- to be and I want that preserve to
isomorphisms so initially I want B to
preserve eight isomorphism so - P - 2
B's find an isomorphic to - a prime
minus 2 a prime so the g AP which we
found earlier in 2b minus 2b is mapped
via this friendly isomorphism to a
proper g AP which we'll call q now
sitting side to a - to it and preserving
the same dimension and sighs so Fryman
isomorphisms are good for preserving
these partial additive structures like
JPS
correct so questions were you saying so
because we have to pass the to be - to
be we want to be - to be to be friendly
isomorphic to - a prime minus 2 a prime
so that's why in the proof I won't be to
be 8 isomorphic to a prime so you see so
I'm skipping details of this step but if
you read the definition of Fryman s
isomorphism you see that this
implication holds no - isomorphism is a
weaker condition to isomorphism just
means that you're preserving two wise
sons think about the definition you're
framing to isomorphism in particular if
two sets are Fryman - isomorphic and you
have a arithmetic progression in one
then that arithmetic progression is also
an arithmetic progression in the other
okay so it's just enough a data
structure to preserve things like
arithmetic progressions and generalized
arithmetic progressions okay so we found
this large GAAP in - a - to it so this
is this is America so we wanted to
contain a in the GAAP seems that playing
out with doing something sliding the
opposite direction we find a large GA P
within - a - to it but something we've
seen before we're going to use this to
boost ourselves to a covering of a via
the Rouge are covering lemma right so
once you find this large structure you
can now try to take translates of it to
cover and this is if there's any take
away from the spirit of this proof is
this idea even though I want to cover
the whole set it's okay I just find a
large structure within it and then I use
translates to cover how do we do this
so since Q is containing 2a minus 2a we
find that Q plus a is containing 3a
minus 2a therefore by Clinique Arusha
clinical Russa inequality the size of Q
plus a is at most the size of 3a minus
2a which is at most K to the fifth power
times the size of a and I claim that
this final quantity is also not so
different from the size of Q right
because okay so all of these I mean the
point here is we are doing all of these
transformations passing down to subsets
putting something bigger putting getting
to something smaller but each time we
only lose something that is polynomial
in K we're not losing much more
I'm also only losing a constant factor
there's sometimes a bit more than more
than polynomial but in any case we're
losing only a constant factor at each
step so in particular since and upper
bounds size a prime and it's larger than
a prime which is at least a constant
fraction of a and the size of Q is at
least one over 40 raised to D times and
so we find that this
bound upper bound earlier on q+ a we can
write it in terms of size of cube where
K prime is put all of these numbers
together what it specifically doesn't
matter so much other than that it is a
constant D is polynomial in K so what we
have here is something that's
exponential in the polynomial of K okay
so now we're in a position to apply the
Rouge are covering lemma so look at that
statement up there so what is it saying
that a plus Q looks like it could be
covered by Q just in terms of size so I
should expect to cover a by a small
number of translates of Q minus Q so by
covering lemma a it's contained in some
X plus Q minus Q for some X where the
size of X is at most K Prime I claim so
we've covered it by something Q is a ga
P X is a bounded size set and I claim
that this is the type of object that
we're happy to have just to spell out
some details first note that X is
contained in a JP dimension x so X minus
1 with length 2 in each direction
to add a new direction for every element
of X it's wasteful but everything is
constant and recall that the dimension
of Q as a G a PSD so X plus Q minus Q is
contained in Ag AP of dimension okay so
what's the dimension also when I do Q
minus Q is like taking a box and
toppling its dimension doubling its
length I'm not changing the number of
dimensions so the dimension of Q minus Q
is still deep a dimension of X is at
most size of X all of these things are
constants so so we're happy but just
spell it out the constant here is K
prime is what we wrote up there this is
a constant and the size right so what is
the size of the gaap that contains this
guy here so I'm expanding X to a GAAP by
adding a new direction for every element
of X and I might expand that size a
little bit but the size of this GAAP
that contains X it's no more than 2 to
the power X - 2 raised to the size of X
when there's the size of the gaap Q - Q
so Q is a JP of dimension D and we know
that a ga P of dimension D has doubling
constant and those two to the D
to to the D times the size of you okay
and because Q is contained in QA - to a
we find that Q is contained in to a - 2
a and 2 to the X well I know what the
size of X is bounded by a prime plus the
size of X is size of X's are most K
prime and then I have 2 to the D over
here - a - to a by Polonia kirusha is
our most K to the for the size of a ok
you put everything together we find that
this bound here is doubly exponential in
the polynomial okay and that's it this
proofs from it's due to recap
we went through several steps so first
using the modeling lemma we know that if
a set a has small doubling then we can
pass a large part of a to a relatively
small cyclic group I'm going to work
inside a cyclic group using bug Labov
lemma and and it's geometry of numbers
corollary which I find that inside the
cyclic group the corresponding set which
we call B it's such that 2 B minus 2 B
contains a large GA P we passed that
gaap back to the original set a because
we are preserving 8 isomorphisms Fryman
8 isomorphisms in Ruza modeling lemma so
we can pass through the origin of set a
and find a large GA P in to a minus 2 a
once we find as large GA p 2a minus 2 a
then we're going to use the Ruza
covering lemma to contain a inside a
small number of translates of this GA p
okay you put all of these things
together and the appropriate bounds
coming from putting the kirusha
inequalities and you get and this is a
proof of Ryman's theorem
okay question how do you make it proper
up and tell the step with Q it is still
proper so the very last step over here
it is you might have destroyed
properties so this proof here doesn't
give you properties so I mention in the
beginning that in Fryman serum you can
obtain properties of the an additional
argument so that I'm not going to show
this some more work which is related to
geometry of numbers so from so for
example you can look up in the textbook
by Tao and you see how to get from a
GAAP to contain it in a proper GAAP
without losing too much in terms of size
so in terms of the man you think about
it this way so how when is an one do you
have something which is not properly
when you have and if some linear
dependence when you have some integer
linear dependence and in that case you
kind of lost the dimension we have
improper news you actually go down the
dimension but then you need to salvage
to the sides to make sure that the size
doesn't blow up too much and so there
are some arguments to be done there and
we're not gonna do so the question is to
get proper nice do I have to modify the
proof oh can I use Freeman's theorem as
witness a black box so my understanding
is that you can use the statements a
black box and obtain properties but if
you want to get good balance maybe you
have to go into the proof I'm not sure
okay
any more questions all right so
so this took a while so this was the
most involved proof we've done in this
course so far
improving Freeman's theorems we had to
develop a large number of tools and we
came up so and we eventually arrived at
you know it's a beautiful theory so this
is a fantastic result
that gives you an inverse structure
something we know that GP s-- have small
doubling and converts s if something has
small doubling it has to in some sense
look like a GP you see that the proof is
quite involved in has a lot of beautiful
ideas in the remainder of today's
lecture I want to present some remarks
on additional extensions and
generalizations of Freeman's theorem and
what we're not going to do any proofs
there's a lot of deep and beautiful
mathematics that are involved in in the
subject so this is I want to take you to
a tour through some of them more things
that we can talk about when it comes to
fragments theorem but first let me
mention a few things that I mentioned
very quickly when we first introduced
Freeman's theorem namely some remarks on
the balance so the proof that we just
saw gives you a pound which is basically
exponential in the dimension and doubly
exponential for the size blow up all
constants so if that's you only care
about constants then then this is just
fine but you might ask are we losing too
much what is the the right type of
dependence so what is the right type of
dependence so we saw in an example so we
saw an example where if you start with a
being a highly dissociated set where
there is basically no additive structure
within a then you do need so this
example shows that you cannot do better
then polynomial well actually that
linear in K in dimension and exponential
in the size blow-up so in particular you
do need to blow up the size to by by
some exponential quantity in K so here K
is in this example and you can you can
create modifications of the example to
keep K constant and a getting larger but
the point is that you cannot do better
than this type of dependence simply from
that example and it's conjecture that
that is the truth we're almost there
improving this conjecture but not quite
although the proof that we just gave is
somewhat far because you lose an
exponent in each bound there is a
refinement of the final step in the
argument so let me comment on that so we
can refine the final step the final
steps and proof to get polynomial pounds
to get polynomial pounds which is much
more in the right ballpark compared to
what we got and the idea is basically
over here we used recovering lemma so we
started with that q up there
up until this point you should think of
this stuff as everything coming from
baklava and its corollary so that stays
the same
another question starting without Q what
would you use how would you use this Q
to try to cover a wholly this a applied
which are covering lemma remember how
the proof which are covering lemma goes
you take a maximal set of translates
destroying translates and if you blow
everything up by a factor to that you
get a cover but it turns out to be
somewhat wasteful you see there's a lot
of wasting going from X to 2 to the X so
you could do that step more slowly so so
starting with Q cover now some not all
of a so cover parts of it by translates
to minus Q so we do reach are covering
them out you don't cover the whole thing
but nibble away cover a little bit and
then look at the thing that you get
which is Q becomes some new thing let's
say Q 1 I now cover more by Q 1 minus Q
1 so apparently if you do the covering
step more slowly you can obtain better
bounce and that's enough to save you
this exponent that go down to
exponential battle to go down to
polynomial type bounds for fragments
theorem this is roughly the idea so you
can modify the final step to obtain this
bound the best bound so far is due to
Tom Sanders who proved Freeman's theorem
for
pounds dimension that's like K times
polynomial of then this poly logarithmic
factor it's basically the right answer
so this proof is much more sophisticated
so it goes goes much more in-depth into
analyzing the structure of set addition
so senders is a very nice survey article
called the structure of said addition
that analyzes some of the modern
techniques that are used to prove these
types of results there is one more issue
which I want to discuss at length in the
second half of this lecture which is
that you might be very unhappy with this
exponential blow-up because if you think
about what happens in these examples or
not the examples but if you think about
what happens like the spirit what we're
trying to say
Fryman Sturm is some kind of an inverse
theorem and to go forward you're trying
to say that if you have a ga P of
dimension D then the size blow up is
like 2 to the D right so we want to say
some structure
price small topic and finance theorem
tells the reverse that you have small
doubling then you obtain this structure
and seems like you are losing I mean
getting from here to here there is a
polynomial type of loss whereas going
from here to here it seems that we're
incurring some exponential type of loss
and you'll be nice to have some kind of
inverse theorem that also preserves
these relationships qualitatively so
that may not make sense in this moment
but we'll get back to it later the
structure point is there's more than
this much more to be said about the
bounds here even though right now it
looks as if they're very close to each
other one more thing that I want to
expand on is we've stated and proved
Freeman's theorem in the integers and
you might ask what about in other groups
we also proved Freeman's theorem in f2
to the M or more generally groups of
bounded exponent of bounded portion so
billion groups have bounded exponent for
general abelian groups so general groups
you might ask what happens here and in
some sense what is even the statement of
the theorem we want something which
combines somehow two different types of
behavior on one hand you have Z which is
what we just did and here the model
structures are G APs and on the other
hand we have which we also proved things
like f2 to the M where the model
structures are subgroups and there's a
sense in which these are not the G ApS
or subgroups they have some similar
properties but they're now really like
each other
so now if I give you a general group
which might be some combination of
infinite portion or very large torsion
elements versus very small portion
elements so for example take a Cartesian
product of these groups is there a
freeman's theorem and what as such a
theorem looked like what are the
structures what are the subsets of
bounded doubly so that's kind of thing
we want to think about so it turns out
for Prime Minster mean fine in general
abelian groups okay so there is a
theorem so this theorem was proved by
Green and Russia
so following a very similar type of
proof framework although it be
individual steps in particular the
modeling lemma needs to be modified and
let me tell you about the statement is
so the common generalization of GA piece
and subgroups is something called a
coset progression so a coset progression
is a subset which is a direct sum of the
form p plus h where p is a proper gaap
definition of GA p works just fine in
every abelian group where you start with
an initial point a few directions and
you look at a great expansion of those
directions piece of property a P and H
is a subgroup and here the direct sum
refers to fact that every so if P plus h
equals to P prime plus h prime for some
P and P Prime Minister set P and H H
prime is a set H then P equals to P
Prime and H
so every element in here is written in a
unique way as some people some age so
that's what I mean by director song for
such an object so such a concept
progression I call it's dimension to be
the dimension of the GA P P and its size
in this case actually it's just the size
of the set which is also the size P
times the size of H so the theorem is
that if a is a subset of an arbitrary
abelian group and it has founded
toppling then a is contained in a coset
progression founded dimension and size
founded blow-up of the size of a and
here these constants P and K they are
universal they do not depend on the
group so there are some specific numbers
functions you can write down they do not
depend on the group so so this theorem
gives you the characterization of
subsets in general abelian groups that
have small toppling any questions
that's a good question so I think you
could go into their paper and see that
you can get polynomial type bounds and I
think Sanders results also work for this
type of setting to give you these type
of bounds but I yeah so she's looking to
Sanders paper and you are explaining I
think incentives paper
he works in general billion groups the
next question I want to address is okay
what do you think is the next question
another billion groups so fragments
theorem in non abelian groups or rather
the Fryman problem now here's a basic
question if I guess there's non abelian
group what subsets I've found the table
of course the examples from abelian
groups also working non abelian groups
well you have subgroups you have
generalized arithmetic progressions but
are they're genuinely new examples of
sets in non abelian groups that have
bounded doubly so think about that and
let's take a quick break
okay can you think of examples seeing
non abelian groups that have small
doubling that do not come from the
examples that we have seen before so let
me show you one construction and this is
an important construction in for non
abelian groups so it has a name it's
called a discrete Heisenberg which is
the matrix consisting of matrices that
look like what I've written so yeah
integer entries above the diagonal one
on the diagonal and zero below the back
so let's do some elementary matrix
multiplication to see how good
multiplication in this group works so if
I have two such matrices I multiply them
together and then you see that the
diagnosed preserved of course but the
this entry over here is simply addition
so this entry here is just addition this
entry over here it's also addition and
the top right entry is a bit more
complicated it's some addition but
there's an additional twist
so this is how matrix multiplication
works in this group I mean this whole
matrix multiplication works but in terms
of so you see it's kind of like an
abelian group but there's an extra twist
so it's almost a billion first step you
can take away from the billion and and
there's a way to quantify this notions
called neo potency so we'll get to that
in a second but in particular if you set
s to be the following generators so if
you take s the babies four elements and
you ask what does the RF power of s
looked like so I look at all the
elements which can be written by our or
and most are elements from s or do these
elements look like what do you think
right so if you look at elements in here
how large can this entry the 1 comma 2
entry be each time you do addition so
it's a most art ok so let me be a bit
rough here and say it's Big O of are and
likewise the 2 1 2 3 entries also Big O
of our what about the top right entry
over here yeah so it grows like R
squared because there's an extra
multiplication term ok so you can be
much more precise about the growth rate
of these individual entries but very
roughly it looks like this over here so
the size of s are all of s is roughly on
the order of fourth power of our
so in particular the doubling constant
ours will be large is what happens we go
from r2 to r2 the size increases by a
factor of around 16 okay so that's an
example of a set in a non abelian group
with founded doubly which is genuinely
different from the examples we have seen
so far right so that's non abelian
questions oh it's a size we've shown the
sizes I'm not being very precise here
but you can do upper bound and lower
bound so it sighs turns out to be the
water of our to the form so you want to
show that there are actually enough
elements over here that you can fill in
but I'll be okay can you build other
examples like this one
okay questions how do we know this isn't
like a cassette some a cassette
progression of one thing this is not a
billion s if you multiply entries of s
in different waters you get different
elements so in already in that way it's
different from the examples that we have
seen before
but no you're right so maybe we can
write this a semi direct product in
terms of things we have seen before and
it is in some sense a semi direct
product but it's a very special kind of
semi direct product okay from that
example you can build bigger examples of
course with more entries in the matrix
but more generally these things are what
are known as neo potent groups right so
there's an example important group and
remind you the definition of a new Putin
group is a group where the lower central
series eventually terminates if you look
hard so this is the commutator of G look
at all the elements within s XY X
inverse Y inverse set of elements that
can be written this way so that's a
subgroup and if I repeat this operation
enough times I eventually would get just
the identity and you could try it on
that group if you do the commutator okay
so you essentially you get rid of a
billion Asst and you move up the Hodag
you know
take a commentator you get rid of this
you zero out these two entries together
Z alone if you do it one more time you
zero out that entry and so more
generally all of these new potent groups
so if you take set of generators and
look at all
and look at the volume of all ha there's
a volume of the bulk grow with the
radius it grows like a polynomial and so
let me define that
so given G a finitely generated coop so
generated by s we say that G has
polynomial growth if the size has to be
our growth like at most a polynomial in
R it's worth noting that this definition
is really a definition about G it does
not depend on the choice of generators
you have different choices generators
for the group but polynomial growth with
respect to one set of generators then
it's the same it's also has polynomial
growth with regards to every other set
so we've seen an example of groups with
polynomial growth abelian groups have
polynomial growth okay so if you think a
polynomial thing you know lattice Z to
the N take a ball growing so it has size
growing like
are to the dimension but no potent group
is another example of groups with
polynomial growth you may want to and
these are intuitive theories for now
related you found the table the
polynomial Coughlin has found a doubling
so is there a classification of groups
with bound with polynomial growth so if
I tell you a group so infinite group
always because other ways finite then
maxes out already at some point so I
give you an infinite group I tell you
has polynomial growth what can you tell
me about this group is there some
characterization that's an inverse of
what we've seen so far and the answer is
yes and this is a famous and deep result
of robot so chromis theorem polynomial
from the 80s romoff showed that a finely
generated virtually new poll where
virtually is an adverb in group theory
when you have some property like a
billion or solvable or whatever so new
virtually P means that there exists a
finite index subject with property P so
virtually no Putin is that there's a
finite index subgroup that is no potent
so it completely characterizes groups of
polynomial growth so basically all the
examples we've seen so far are
representatives so up to changing by a
finite index subgroup
expect shouldn't change the growth
nature by so much there are some
analogies to be made here with for
example in geometry you ask in Euclidean
space how fast is the ball of radius R
grown in dimension T it grows like R to
the D what about in the hyperbolic space
does anyone know how fast in hyperbolic
space ball of radius R grows it's
exponential in the radius so for now
negatively curved spaces the boss grow
polynomially but for something that's
negatively curvature in particular the
hyperbolic space the ball growth might
be exponential you have a similar
phenomenon happening here the opposite
of polynomial growth is super polynomial
growth but one specific example is that
of a free group where there are no
relations between the generators in that
case the balls they grow like
exponentially the all-school
exponentially in the radius groom offs
there is a deep theorem and it's
original proof used some very hard tools
coming from geometry and Gromov
developed a notion of convergence of
metric spaces somewhat akin to our
discussion of graph limits so starting
with discrete objects you looked at some
convergence to some continuous objects
and then used some very deep results
from the classification of locally
compact groups to derive this result
over here
so this proof has been quite influential
and it's related to something called
Hilbert's fifth problem which concern
characterizations of B groups inverse
high problems and tell you some
structure has some property describe
that structure okay what does this all
have to do with fragments theorem
well already you see some relation right
so there seemed at least intuitively
some relationship between groups of
polynomial growth versus subsets have
found the doubling a one implies the
other although not in the converse and
they are indeed we dated and this comes
out of some very recent work oh I should
also mention that Cuomo's theorem has
been major simplified by kleiner who
gave an important simplification more
elementary proof of grow MOFs
theorem okay so let's talk about a non
abelian version of Fryman still we would
like some result that says that it's a
true that every set must every set so
previously we had a small table you want
to have some similar notion although it
might not be exactly small doubling but
let me not be very precise and to say
hold small doubling in literature these
things are sometimes also known as
approximate groups you catch the
relevant literature on this subject most
every set of small doubling in some non
abelian group behave like one of these
known examples something which is some
combination
of subgroups and no potent balls so
these combinations are sometimes known
as Cosette Neal progressions so this was
very this was something that was only
explore in the past ten years or so and
a series of very difficult works
previously have been known and still
it's being investigated for various
special classes of matrix groups or
special classes of groups like solve a
group solvable groups and whatnot that
are more explicit or easier to handle or
closer to the abelian analog there was
important work of push off scheme which
was published about ten years ago who
showed using model theory techniques so
using methods from logic that a weak
version of Freeman's theorem is true and
later on
Priya green and hell building on
Kirchhoff's kiss work so this actually
came quite a bit later even though the
journal publication dates are the same
year so they were able to build on
Kirchhoff's keys work and but greatly
expanding on it and going back to some
of the older techniques coming from
Gilbert's fifth problem and as a result
proved an inverse structure theorem that
gave some kind of answer to this
question of non abelian Fryman so we now
do have some theorem which is like
Fryman Sturm for abelian groups that
says in a bit non abelian group if you
have something that resembles small
doubling then the set must in some sense
look like a combination
of subgroups and neo potent boss but let
me not be precise at all the methods
here build on Kirchhoff's key and which
also used model theory which is kind of
I mean it's something we're okay in
particular one feature of all of these
proofs is that they give no bounds
similar to what we seen earlier in the
course improves our involved compactness
what happens here is that the arguments
use ultra filters so there are these
constructions from mathematical logic
and like compactness they give no bats
so it remains an open problem to proof
Fryman stands for non abelian groups
with some concrete bands question so
what is new potent bomb I wouldn't want
to give a precise definition but roughly
speaking it's balls that come out of
those types of constructions right so
you take a new potent subgroup you take
an important group you look at the image
when you're potent group into your group
and then look at the image of that ball
so something that looks like one of the
previous constructions okay so that's
all I want to say about non abelian
extensions are fragments theorem any
questions okay so what I mean by so you
can look in the papers to see the
precise definitions but roughly speaking
it's that if you have therefore one
there are different kinds of definitions
and most of them are equivalent but one
versions that you have a set a such that
a a is coverable by hey
so to bid more than just the size
information but it's actually related to
size information so we've already seen
its course how many of these different
notions you can go back and forth from
one to the other I'm covering two to
size and whatnot okay
the final thing I want to discuss today
is one of the most central open problems
in additive combinatorics going back to
the abelian version so this is known as
the polynomial Fryman Rouge our
conjecture
so we would like some kind of a Fryman
theorem that preserves the constants up
to polynomial changes without losing an
exponent from earlier discussions I
showed you that the bounds that we
almost proved is close to the truth you
do need some kind of exponential loss in
the blow-up size of the GA p but it
turns out those kind of examples are
slightly misleading all right so let's
look at the examples the constructions
again so if a so just for simplicity
exposition I'm going to stick with f2 to
the N at least initially so if a is an
independent set of size and then okay
being the doubling constant of a trophy
like n over 2 and yet the subgroup that
contains a size true to be something on
the water okay times hey so you
necessarily incur an exponential loss
over here now you might complain what
the size of a here is basically K but of
course I can blow up this example by
considering what happens if you take
each element here
into entire subspace so these are the
coordinate vectors so now I'm sitting
inside F 2 to the M plus N and that
gives you this set the toppling constant
is still the same as before and yet we
see that the generated by a still has
this exponential blow-up in this
constant exponential in the doubling
constant but now you see in this example
here even though the subgroup generated
by a can be much larger than a by so
everything's still constant so much
largest in terms of them as a function
of the toppling constant a has a very
large structure so a has contains a very
large subspace subspace I mean a fine
subspace and this subspace here is
comparable to the size of a itself so
you might wonder if you don't care about
containing a inside a single subspace
can you do much better in terms of
bounds and that's the content of the
polynomial frame intruder conjecture or
conjecture for f2 to the M says that if
you have a subset of f2 to the M and a
plus a is size and most K times the size
of a then there exists a subspace V of
size at most
such that the contains a large
proportion and the large year we only
lose something that is polynomial in
these doubling constants so that's the
case over here so instead of containing
a in the inside an entire subspace
I just want to contain a large fraction
of a in a subspace and the conjecture is
that I do not need to incur exponential
losses in the constants question is V an
affine subspace you can think of V s
mattifying south chase you can think of
V is a subspace it doesn't actually
matter in this formulation okay
there's an equivalent formulation which
you might like better where initially my
complaint well initially PFR is
initially Fryman terms about covering it
and now we've only covered a part of it
of course we saw from earlier arguments
you can use recovering lam article from
covering a part of a to covering all of
it
indeed is this the case that this
formulation is equivalent to the
formulation that if a the same after the
N and a plus a sighs the most K times a
then there exists some subspace V with
the size of e no larger than the size of
a such that a can be covered by
polynomial in K many Co sets we see that
here here a has doubling constant K
which is around the same as and and even
though I cannot contain a by a single
subspace of well fee the same size I can
use K different translates to cover a
any questions so I want to leave it to
you as an exercise to prove that these
two versions are equivalent to each
other
okay so it's not too hard so it's on
something I have more time I would show
you it's useless
roots are covering lemma to prove this
equivalence the nice thing about the
poly no polynomial frame illusion
conjecture pfr conjecture is considered
a central conjecture in additive
combinatorics because it has many
equivalent formulation and relate to
many problems that are central to the
subject so we would like some kind of an
inverse theorem that gives you these
polynomial bounds and I'll mention a
couple of these equivalent formulations
here's an important formulation which is
rather attractive where instead of
considering subsets we're going to
formulate something that has to do with
approximate homomorphisms so the
statements are still conjecture is that
if it's a function from moving in space
to another podium space is such that F
is approximately a homomorphism in a
sense that the set of possible errors if
it's actually a homomorphism and this
quantity is always equal to zero but
it's approximately a whole more physical
in the sense that the set of such errors
is bounded by K in size the conclusion
so the conjecture claims that then there
exists an actual homomorphism an actual
linear map
G
such that F is very close to G as in
that the set of possible discrepancies
between F and G yes Bank where you only
lose a most polynomial in K so if you
are an approximate homomorphism in this
sense then you're actually very close to
an actual linear map now it is not too
hard to prove a much weaker
quantitatively weaker version of the
statement so I claim that it is trivial
to show upper bound of at most two to
the K over here so think about why so if
I give you an F I can just think about
what the values of F are on the basis
and extend it to a linear map this set
it's necessarily a span of that set so
has size at most 2 to the K but it's
open to show you only have to lose a
polynomial in
[Applause]
there's also a version of the polynomial
frame illusion conjecture which is
related to things we've discussed
earlier regarding some Reddy's theorem
and in fact the the polynomial Fryman
Ruza conjecture kind of came back into
popularity partly because of cowers
proof of some rarities theorem that used
many of these tools so let me state it
here okay so we've seen some statement
like this in an earlier lecture but but
not very precisely not precisely in this
form i won't define you all the notation
here but hopefully you get a rough sense
of what what it's about so we want some
kind of an inverse statement for
quadratic uniformity more
so recall back to our discussion of
proof of Roth's theorem a Fourier
analytic proof of roster we want to say
that but now think about not three a ps4
four ATP's so we want to know if you
have a function the pudding cube and
this function is unbounded and I'm going
to write down some notation which we are
not going to define but the cowers u3
norm is at least some Delta so this is
something which is related to for AP
counts so in particular if this number
is small then you have a counting number
for for term arithmetic progressions
if this is true then there exists a
quadratic polynomial Q n variables over
f2 such that your function f correlates
with this quadratic exponential in Q and
the correlation here is something where
you have you only lose a polynomial in
the parameters so previously I quoted
something where you lose something
that's only a constant in Delta and that
is true that is no we believe so it's a
conjecture that you only do so
polynomial in these parameters so this
type of statement remember now prove a
roster something like this came up so
something like this came up as a crucial
step in the proof of roster if you have
something where you look at counting
lemma you exhibit something like this
then you can exhibit a large Fourier
character and in higher worded Fourier
analysis something like this corresponds
to a large four-year care having a large
Fourier transform it turns out that all
of these formulations of polynomial
Fryman lucha conjectures are equivalent
to each other and they're all equivalent
in a very quantitative sense so upto
polynomial changes depends so
particularly if you can prove some
bounds for some version then that
automatically leads to balance for the
other versions it was proof of
equivalence is just not trivial but it's
also it's not too complicated take some
work but it's not too complicated the
best bounds for the polynomial Fryman
ruzic
injector and thanks for all of these
versions is again due to Tom Sanders and
he proved a version of PFR with
quasi-polynomial balanced with high
quality polynomial bounds I mean for
instance over here instead of K he
proved it for something which is like e
to the poly log K so like K to the log K
but K to the poly knocking so it's
almost polynomial but not quite there
and it's considered a central open
problem to better understand the
polynomial Fryman Ruza conjecture and we
believe that this is something that
could be to a lot of important new tools
and techniques that are relevant to the
rest of additive combinatorics
okay so question is so we know that that
up there has 2 to the K okay so you're
asking can you use this 2 to the K to
get some bound for polynomial before for
something like this and and the answer
is yes so you can use that proof to go
through some proofs and get here I don't
remember how this equivalence goes but
now remember that the proof of Freeman's
theorem for f2 to the N wasn't so hard
right so we didn't use very many tools
unfortunately I don't have time to tell
you the formulations of polynomial
Fryman which a congestion over the
integers and also over are billion
arbitrary abelian groups but there are
formulations over the integers and and
that's one that people care just as much
about and and there are also different
equivalent versions but things are a bit
nicer in the boolean case I'm sorry can
you repeat the question
well this is me ah so this is what's
called a coward uniformity norm okay so
something I encourage the male cop in
fact there's an unassigned problem in
problem set that's related to the couch
uniformity no one before you - which is
related for analysis but you three years
we did it - for EPS and quadratic for
urinalysis